we can speak now to gina miller the
businesswoman who took the british
government to court over article fifty
she's now legally a tactical voting
campaign called best for britain and
joins us now from westminster jeanne
good evening to you now you've been
campaigning for candidates who'll stop a
heart brexit how do you think you've
been doing well we think we've done
remarkably well the tactical dashboard
have we've had thousands upon thousands
of visits i have to say the top two
searches and constituency wise have
actually been Maidenhead and Vauxhall so
which has been rather surprising for us
but we've the first part of our campaign
getting a high turnout for young people
and women we've managed to get hundreds
of thousands of people to do that
obviously registering to vote is not the
same as turning out tomorrow but we hope
we are spending an awful lot of energy
trying to get people to turn out
tomorrow and we've got 36 champions that
we've identified as people who will
stand up in Parliament and put their
country before their careers and go for
this minimising of damage that we want
to see in the negotiations and yet you
say this but yeah the only party that's
been campaigning overtly against brexit
has been the Liberal Democrats and by
common consensus they've had a pretty
shocking campaign their poll ratings of
have slipped during the campaign I don't
think I I don't think we can look
backwards this is not about undoing
brexit and I don't actually agree with
the second referendum what I'm talking
about is damage limitation and I think
whoever the next government are and I
think it will be a Conservative
government and I hope it is with a
working majority but not a huge
landslide I think that's what will be
best for Britain that we go into this
with trying to fight for access to the
single market because I think that's the
only way we can guarantee as as Lord
Maud said you know a stability that's
required and what's best for business
and what's best for our economy are you
surprised at how little brexit seems to
being discussed since the manifestos
were launched I mean everyone said this
was a brexit election it hasn't really
been so has it well Mrs May herself said
this was a brexit election and and I
think this is a hugely wasted
opportunity we could have seen more on
policy we could have seen more on
direction of travel and that
opportunity's been thrown away I think
with a terribly managed campaign I mean
the social care debacle was just a mess
has really damaged their campaign and of
course then the terrible occurrences as
atrocities that was obviously outside of
everyone's control but that has dented
the campaign as well what about this
osed warning today on a harbor exit I
mean Lord gave some suggestions just now
as to how the government can offset that
what would you recommend I'm always very
intrigued this idea that a no deal is
better than a bad deal because what
happens after the No Deal there is
absolutely no no conversation about that
no deal . but no detail no no how do we
then operate in the limbo that we'll be
in there's absolutely I'm aghast at the
lack of detail in that statement but do
you have confidence in Theresa made to
deliver a good brexit deal for the UK I
think she has to be held accountable it
I don't believe that some mandates she
has from the people we'll see on Friday
morning because it's very clear in them
in the manifesto if that's what the vote
is for and she does have a landslide
then the rest of us will just have to
sort of say what she has this mandate
now but I don't believe she'll have that
I think the country wants access to the
single market we've done research at
best for Britain which found we actually
surveyed remain and leave 50% of both in
our survey and 50% of people said they
want access to the single market as
opposed to 21 percent who said No